we all know about the dinosaurs that
once roamed the planet but long after
they went extinct great beasts we call
the megafauna lived on every continent
in the Americas ground sloths the size
of elephants pull down trees with their
claws saber-toothed cats the size of
brown bears hunted in packs but there
were no match for short face bears which
stood 13 feet on their hind legs and are
likely to have driven these cats away
from their prey
there were armadillos as big as small
cars an eight-foot beaver and a bird
with a 26 foot wingspan almost
everywhere the world's megafauna
would driven to extinction often by
human hunters some species still survive
in parts of Africa and Asia in other
places you can still see the legacy of
these great beasts most trees are able
to re sprout where their trunk is broken
to withstand the loss of much of their
bark and survive splitting twisting and
trampling partly because they evolved to
survive attacks by elephants the
American pronghorn can run so fast
because it evolved to escape the
American cheetah the surviving animals
live in Ghost ecosystems adapted to
threats from species that no longer
exist
today it may be possible to resurrect
those ghosts to bring back lost species
using genetic material for instance
there's been research into cloning
woolly mammoths from frozen remains but
even if it's not possible we can still
restore many of the ecosystems the world
is lost how by making use of abandoned
farms as the market for food is
globalized infertile land becomes
uncompetitive farmers in barren places
can't compete with people growing crops
on better land elsewhere as a result
farming has started to retreat from many
regions and trees have started to return
one estimate claims that 2/3 of land in
the u.s. that was once forested but was
cleared for farming has become forested
again another estimate suggested by 2030
an area in Europe the size of Poland
will be vacated by farmers
even if we can't use DNA to bring back
ground sloths and giant armadillos we
can restore bears wolves
Pumas Lynx moose and bison to the places
where they used to live some of these
animals can reshape their surroundings
creating conditions that allow other
species to thrive when wolves were
reintroduced to the Yellowstone National
Park in 1995 they quickly transformed
the ecosystem where they reduced the
numbers of overpopulated deer vegetation
began to recover the height of some
trees Quinn tupled in just six years as
forests returned
so did songbirds beavers which heat
trees multiplied in the rivers and their
dams provided homes for otters muskrats
ducks frogs and fish the wolves killed
coyotes allowing rabbits and mice to
increase providing more food for hawks
weasels foxes and badgers bald eagles
and ravens fed in the carrion that the
Wolves abandoned
so did bears which also ate the berries
on the returning shrubs licen numbers
rose as they browse the revitalized
forests the Wolves changed almost
everything this is an example of a
trophic cascade a change at the top of
the food chain that tumbles all the way
to the bottom affecting every level the
discovery of widespread trophic cascades
may be one of the most exciting
scientific findings of the past half
century they tell us that ecosystem
serve lots just one or two species of
large animals can behave in radically
different ways from those that retain
them all over the world new movements
are trying to catalyze the restoration
of nature in a process called rewilding
this means undoing some of the damage
we've caused re-establishing species
which have been driven out and then
stepping back there is no attempt to
create an ideal ecosystem to produce a
heath a rainforest or a coral reef
rewilding is about bringing back the
species that drive dynamic processes and
then letting nature take its course but
it's essential that rewilding must never
be used as an excuse to push people off
the land
it should happen only with the consent
and enthusiasm of the people who work
there imagine standing on a cliff in
England watching sperm whales attacking
shoals of herring as they did within
sight of the shore until the 18th
century by creating marine reserves in
which no commercial fishing takes place
that can happen again
imagine a European Serengeti full of the
animals it used to live there
hippos rhinos elephants hyenas and lions
what rewilding reintroduces alongside
the missing animals and plants is that
rare species called hope it tells us
that ecological change need not always
proceed in the same direction the Silent
Spring could be followed by a wild
summer